Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonsoir.
Accro à la météo ?
C’est vrai, c’est une passion
qui ne m’a jamais quitté
et j’ai la chance aujourd’hui de pouvoir
la vivre quotidiennement.
Mais je suis aussi inquiet
face au réchauffement climatique
et j’essaye à mon niveau
de parler au grand public pour expliquer,
essayer de montrer justement,
quels sont les enjeux
de ce réchauffement climatique
qui est souvent victime
d’idées reçues, de préjugés.
On va essayer de déconstruire
tout ça en quelques minutes.
Le premier élément
que je voulais aborder avec vous,
c’est d’abord :
« Qu’est-ce qu’on constate ? »
À l’échelle du territoire,
s’il y a un chiffre à retenir,
c’est que le réchauffement est de l’ordre
de 0,2 à 0,5 °C tous les dix ans.
Ça ne semble pas grand-chose dit comme ça,
mais faut savoir qu’entre
Clermont-Ferrand et le Mont-Dore,
il n’y a que 4 degrés de différence
de température en moyenne.
Au regard du rythme actuel, dans 50 ans,
la température moyenne qu’on avait
à Clermont-Ferrand dans les années 70
correspondrait à celle du Mont-Dore.
C’est une évolution
qui est vraiment très rapide.
Il y a un premier biais par rapport à ce
réchauffement, c’est en fait le ressenti.
Ça veut dire que souvent nous,
on va jouer selon notre propre ressenti.
Je prends l’exemple de l’été dernier.
L’été 2021, il a été vécu
par beaucoup comme pourri.
Si on regarde les graphiques
qui sont derrière moi,
grâce aux statistiques, on se rend compte
que 2021 n’a pas été un été pourri,
parce qu’en fait on a
une température moyenne à Aulnat
qui a été légèrement supérieure
à la moyenne
avec des précipitations excessives.
Mais par le passé, il y a eu des étés qui
étaient encore plus « pourris » que ça.
Il suffit de voir les années
avant les années 80.
En fait, c’était beaucoup plus frais
que ce qu’on a vécu l’été dernier.
Au classement, on peut dire
que l’été dernier,
c’était le 17e le plus chaud
depuis 70 ans environ
et le 15e le plus pluvieux.
Donc pas de caractère
vraiment exceptionnel.
Le problème du ressenti, c’est que,
nous, on a un corps à 37 degrés.
On est des humains, donc forcément,
on peut rapidement avoir froid.
Mais avoir froid ne veut pas dire qu’il
fait froid par rapport à une moyenne.
Pour vous donner aussi une indication,
il faut savoir qu’à Clermont-Ferrand,
la température moyenne
des maximales l’été,
ce n’est pas 35 ou 40 degrés,
c’est 26 degrés.
Et 40 degrés l’été à Clermont-Ferrand,
en 50 ans, ça n’a été atteint
que trois fois, dont deux fois en 2019,
ce qui montre bien que
ce n’est pas tous les étés.
Il y a notre ressenti,
mais aussi les médias.
Aujourd’hui, les médias vont jouer
sur tout ce qui est sensationnel,
tout ce qui est spectaculaire,
et on va mettre tous les phénomènes météo
sur le dos du réchauffement climatique,
alors que beaucoup de phénomènes
n’y sont pas liés.
Ainsi on va décrédibiliser
l’évolution en cours.
Prenez les orages de grêle l’été,
les médias titrent :
« C’est le réchauffement. »
Alors qu’en fait, les orages
de grêle l’été, c’est normal.
On a aussi les extrêmes du printemps -
on passe de la neige à la chaleur,
au froid, ça n’arrête pas de changer -
mais c’est la définition du printemps.
C’est-à-dire que le printemps,
c’est une saison d’extrêmes.
On a une course au buzz,
à l’audience, une course aux clics.
Et tout ça peut décrédibiliser
ce qui se passe vraiment.
Donc il faut faire attention
à ces biais personnels,
notamment le ressenti,
et aussi au niveau des médias.
« Que faire ? », vous allez me dire.
Moi, je suis convaincu qu’il faut être
conscient de la réalité scientifique
de ce qu’on observe actuellement.
Il faut mettre de côté
tous les biais personnels qu’on a
et essayer d’aller plus loin que
ce que les médias peuvent dire.
Les médias ont aussi leur rôle à jouer.
Il faudrait qu’ils expliquent davantage,
qu’ils nuancent surtout,
qu’ils contextualisent.
Et là, on pourrait avoir un discours
qui serait beaucoup plus pédagogique.
Dernier point - et je pense que c’est
ce qu’on peut faire tous facilement -
c’est ce que j’appellerais
l’émerveillement.
Aujourd’hui, on est tous
un peu déconnectés de la nature.
J’ai envie de dire : « Allez voir ce qui
se passe dehors, essayez de comprendre. »
On a une diversité énorme de climats ici,
donc n’hésitez pas,
émerveillez-vous et peut-être
qu’on pourra améliorer les choses.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)